time to listen up you silly liberal
fruitcakes
i came out here i wanted to tell some
jokes let's do some reality checks here
you have any idea sir how pathetic it
must be to be you these people wanted to
come out and have a good time hear a few
jokes some thoughtful discussion but
your head pops off the pillow in the
morning with oh how can i be a
professional victim today let me go in
and screw with their act just because oh
my god your parents didn't tell you that
your opinion wasn't worth that much look
look they're confused they're confused
you know why because i'm not your gender
studies profession who has to cater to
your trigger warning microaggression
safe space [ __ ]
i didn't want to do this i wanted to
come out and tell a few jokes you
created this monster we have to go ten
more minutes of this let this
reverberate let it be a life lesson this
monster right here that you're so afraid
of the face you see in your nightmares
was created by social justice warrior
[ __ ] like you
[Applause]